we find everywhere actually that the
best option is always to divide into
triangles because any 3d surface in the
universe is able to be approximated by
fitting together triangles in talking
about how 3d computer-generated images
are created and how they work there are
a number of different questions that we
need to address and problems that we
need to solve and the first of those is
how do we take a 3d object and represent
it in the computer and so the way we do
this is by using a coordinate system
with every day.we maps and graphs and
things that all use this coordinate
systems got the Cartesian coordinate
system generally we have two axes one
collects one go why if we want to
specify a point any point anywhere on
the graph we have two numbers which
represent the distances that we travel
along each axis so if we have point two
one we go one two one that's point to
one simple enough using this system we
can represent any unique point anywhere
on the plane described by these axes and
we can also you know go this way and
this way to have negative points as well
so that's plus X plus y minus X minus y
and this way we can have -2 minus 1 here
so that's two dimensions but sir if we
want to specify points in three
dimensions we simply add another axis
going through the middle like this it's
perpendicular to x and y but obviously
it's a 2d piece of papers and this is
called Zed so we'll go up plus Z and
this - Zed so now we can have point two
one and this is on plane zero in Zed so
that's 2 1 0 and this becomes minus 2
minus 1 0 using this system and three
number coordinates we can specify any
unique point
relative to the origin here and the axes
that we've specified what uses this when
we want to describe something like a
pyramid well typically what we want to
do is use our coordinate system to
specify the cornice of the objects which
we call vertices
let's get another piece of bakery let's
describe the points of our pyramid using
our 3d coordinate system let's call them
a B C D and then round the back e
using our coordinates a will be at 0 to
0 say B will be at minus 1 in X 0 and y
-1 in Zed C will be at plus 1 in X 0 in
Y minus 1 in Zed and so on for the other
two using these coordinates we can
specify the corners or the vertices of
our objects but that's not quite enough
because all we're doing is specifying
the corners and our representation says
nothing at all about the faces of the
pyramid so how do we go about
representing the faces well one way of
doing it a simple way would be to
specify a new set of vertices three
vertices three coordinates for every
face so we'll have one here one here one
here one here one here one here one here
one here one here etc the problem is
this incurs a lot of duplication of
vertices so for example this vertex at
the top point a on the diagram is
required by all four of these faces so
if we're specifying three coordinates
for every face we're duplicating the top
one four times for a simple object like
pyramid that's not too much of a problem
but if we have a model with a hundred
thousand vertices in then the wastage
can be quite considerable so there is a
better system for specifying the faces
of any geometry and to do that we use a
separate data structure to represent the
faces which references the vertices that
we've described using our Cartesian
coordinates so if we name them as we
have done on the diagram a b c we can
then say that this face is represented
by vertices ABC and this faces a CD and
then this face is a de and then this
face is a B and then we have a problem
because when we come to represent the
base of the pyramid it's a square and
that doesn't really fit into our system
of three vertices per face so what we
could do is find some way of specifying
that these faces all have three vertices
each and this one has four and for
another shape it might have five
vertices or something like that but in
practice it's simpler
just to split the base into two
triangles we find everywhere actually
that the best option is always to divide
into triangles because any 3d surface in
the universe is able to be approximated
by fitting together triangles why
triangles so good for this purpose and
but first of all it's the simplest
polygon there's only three vertices in a
in a triangle second of all and more
importantly any arrangements of three
vertices in 3d space will always be
coplanar which means that no matter how
you arrange the three vertices of a
triangle
they will always lie on the same plane
in space which is a crucial property if
you want to approximate a surface with a
simple two-dimensional polygon or set of
them and it doesn't work for other types
of polygons so a rectangle for example
in this case it's okay because the
vertices are all coplanar they're nice
and flat but if I were to lift one of
them let's go with this one out of the
plane of the other three we no longer
have a valid rectangle because these
three or are coplanar but this isn't I
mean there's got a curved surface to it
so it's not a proper rectangle anymore
so for that reason using rectangles or
higher-order shapes other than triangles
are surfaces that we are approximating
might be in danger of having degenerate
faces faces that aren't properly
represented because we might have one
vertex that's raised down to the plane
of the face but triangles don't suffer
from this problem sean has asked me now
to demonstrate how a cylinder might be
represented by triangles so let's draw
some triangles onto it
so let's start the circle at the top
generally it's quite easy to subdivide
into triangles but what we find is that
this curved edge here will start to look
a little bit Jaggi with these straight
edges not drawn on very well but of
course the more triangles we use the
better the approximation to the circle
so as we add more and more these
straight lines approximate a curve
better and better on the side of the
cylinder we just use almost exactly the
same principle we can create triangles
like this I mean there are millions of
ways to do and it's the same situation
is on the top whereby the more triangles
we have the denser the tessellation the
better approximation to the curved
surface will get so as you see I mean
any surface pretty much this a sphere
anything can be represented by triangles
and need conceivable surface in the
universe in three dimensions at any rate
so there's a further problem in that
when we specify a triangle
a big city we're really specifying two
triangles one on the front and one on
the back in the pyramid we have the
triangles facing out in the triangles
facing in and sometimes we might want to
be able to differentiate between which
way a triangle is facing is it facing
out or is it facing in and the way that
is achieved is by being very careful
about the order in which the vertex
coordinates is specified it's called
winding when you basically decide yes
because your wine the winding the
indices the trick is we always go in one
direction clockwise or anti-clockwise it
doesn't matter which as long as we're
consistent so let's say and in fact I'll
actually done that here that going
anti-clockwise means a face is going
outwards clockwise means a face is
pointing inwards so let's have a look on
this pyramid here we can see that ABC
that's going anti-clockwise this face is
facing out a CD yep they're going
anti-clockwise this face is facing and
now the back face which is facing away
from us
it's a d E which is going clockwise so
that's facing away from us so this way
we can differentiate between triangles
that are facing out or facing in which
becomes very useful for example when
we're drawing a triangle we might want
to say well don't render the faces that
are facing away from us
we want to call those and not bother
having to shade the pixels for those
back to faces or we might want to say
well we don't want to draw the faces
that are looking towards us because we
want to see the inside of an objective
when rendering go cut away or something
like that and so that's how winding
works in a nutshell it doesn't matter
whether you go clockwise for forward
front faces and anti-clockwise for back
faces or the other way around as long as
you're consistent because further down
the pipeline when we come to turn these
triangles into pixels it might become
important to know whether it's facing
away or towards us
we've probably now covered enough to
know roughly how geometry is represented
inside the computer we can represent
vertices and faces made up of vertices
the next step is to take our description
of an object and move it around in 3d
space